Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Vi parlerò di come lavora
uno psichiatra in urgenza,
di come funziona la sua mente.
Sono cose che non sono scritte
nei protocolli, ma poi -
Allora, mettiamo che voi siete
uno psichiatra,
che lavora in un reparto
psichiatrico ospedaliero.
In ogni grosso ospedale
c'è un reparto di questo tipo.
Telefonano dal pronto soccorso,
e vi dicono: c'è una persona
in psicosi acuta.
La psicosi acuta è, più o meno,
il 50% delle richieste
di visita in pronto soccorso.
È una situazione di confusione,
in cui una persona è confusa.
E anche per questo, è irrequieta.
Cioè, se una persona è confusa
non controlla la motilità,
il suo comportamento,
quindi in genere sono, anche,
persone irrequiete,
se non proprio in agitazione.
Tu vai, e c'è chi va lento perché pensa:
se passa un po' di tempo,
le cose magari si sistemano;
chi va tranquillamente veloce
perché è curioso,
e perché poi il Pronto Soccorso
in realtà è un posto abbastanza simpatico,
è meno noioso di un reparto ospedaliero.
La prima cosa che fai -
da qui ve la racconto in tempo reale -
la prima cosa che fai è che vai
dal medico che ti ha chiamato
e gli dici: cosa c'è?
E lui ti dice: c'è uno
che non capisce niente.
E tu gli dici:
- Ci sono dei parenti? - No.
- Ma hai delle notizie? - No.
- Ha dei documenti? - No.
- Va bene. Ciao, vado.
Spesso è così.
Mentre vi avvicinate al paziente,
voi già lo guardate
e già cercate di avere
un orientamento diagnostico.
Noi siamo dei grandi
osservatori, in sostanza:
cerchiamo qualsiasi segno,
qualsiasi cosa nel paziente
che ci possa dare delle indicazioni.
Perché il problema, in Pronto Soccorso,
è che la confusione
può essere anche legata
a dei disturbi di tipo neurologico
o a malattie fisiche.
Può essere un tumore cerebrale,
può essere -
e poi a malattie psichiatriche,
che sono diverse.
Quindi il problema della diagnosi esiste,
nella psichiatria d’urgenza:
cioè bisogna farla e velocemente.
Quindi noi vediamo
come il paziente si muove,
e come si guarda intorno:
i vestiti, i cappelli, le scarpe,
se ha degli zaini, la pelle,
qualsiasi cosa.
Quando siamo vicini,
anche come odora: tutto.
Il problema è che, spesso,
non ci si riesce ad avvicinare
più di tanto al paziente
perché il paziente,
essendo proprio confuso, e irrequieto,
magari cammina per il Pronto Soccorso,
quindi tu gli devi andare dietro.
Incontri un collega,
ti dice: cosa fai qui?
Eh, sto cercando
di visitare questo paziente.
Ma frequentissimamente,
le visite di questo tipo
si fanno camminando,
e il paziente esce anche dal pronto -
io sono uscito dal pronto molte volte.
Esci, e cerchi di -
Anche perché, davanti
al nostro Pronto Soccorso,
c'è una strada molto trafficata,
e poi c'è un muraglione
di 30 metri, che scende giù.
Quindi, il discorso del paziente
che esce dal Pronto è abbastanza -
insomma, bisogna stare attenti.
Il problema è attirare
l'attenzione del paziente.
Questi pazienti sono confusi:
quindi non sanno chi sono loro;
non sanno chi sei tu;
non sanno che quello è un Pronto Soccorso.
La realtà è molto confusa.
Non è che tu vieni vestito
da medico, tutto elegante,
e come succede in altre specialità
dicono: "È arrivato il medico".
Tu sei un pezzo dell'arredamento,
quindi tu devi dire:
(Gesticola)
sono qua, mi ascolta?
Sì.
E gli devi dare delle coordinate:
Lei è - se sai il nome, gli dici:
"Lei si chiama così è così",
perché lui non lo sa.
Gli dici: lei si chiama così e così;
è nell'Ospedale tal dei tali;
io sono un medico; lei è confuso;
sto cercando di capire cosa succede.
Cosa succede?
Questa cosa qui conviene dirla sempre,
perché i pazienti delle volte -
poi ve lo dico meglio -
capiscono, che tu stai cercando
di comunicare con loro.
Comunque, glielo dici:
nella maggior parte dei casi,
il paziente non ti risponde.
Il paziente fa così,
si gira dall'altra parte e se ne va.
È mutacico, oppure straparla.
Perché il problema
è che questo tipo di pazienti
hanno perduto la capacità
di interpretare
il significato delle parole,
cioè le parole hanno perso il significato.
Sono dei rumori, oppure
vogliono dire tutto e niente.
Oppure, dicono -
negli schizofrenici, una parola
ha un significato e il suo contrario,
cioè non riescono proprio
a maneggiare, ad ascoltare le parole.
E non solo le parole:
hanno perduto anche la grammatica.
Le parole, per essere espresse,
devono essere messe in un discorso
con una grammatica.
Loro hanno perso il senso
dei soggetti della grammatica,
cioè i soggetti -
io, tu, lei, voi, noi, essi -
è tutta una confusione.
I tempi verbali dei verbi,
il passato, presente e futuro:
è tutta una confusione.
Hanno perso anche i nessi
di causa ed effetto,
che sono espressi dai verbi
sia transitivi che intransitivi.
Non sanno usare la lingua.
Guardate che non hanno tutti i torti:
cioè, gli psichiatri un pochettino -
anche loro non hanno molta... non fiducia,
ma pensano che la lingua, le parole,
servano abbastanza a poco.
A noi piace lavorare su un livello
lievemente inferiore,
più primitivo rispetto alla lingua.
Quindi, i pazienti
ci sono simpatici di per sé,
nel senso: ci si potrebbe anche intendere.
Però, in realtà, perdere la lingua
è una cosa abbastanza tragica,
nel senso che non è
la grammatica della mente, questa:
però è la grammatica
di un livello superiore della mente
che usa la lingua,
ed è comunque un aspetto
del mondo che è corretto.
Però, per esempio, la parola è in sostanza
un coltello che taglia la realtà,
fa un pezzettino della realtà.
Se io dico "tavolo", separo "tavolo"
da "quello che non è tavolo".
Però, la realtà si può
tagliare a pezzettini?
Uno scienziato - mettiamo
un chimico, o un fisico -
loro possono e tagliano
la realtà in maniera diversa.
Per esempio, se voi avete
un rilevatore di calore,
e il tavolo ha la stessa temperatura
dell'aria che c'è intorno,
voi non distinguete il tavolo,
perché ha la stessa temperatura dell'aria.
Un extraterrestre che avesse
questo sistema, o degli altri,
ha una visione della realtà diversa.
Quindi, per comunicare
con un extraterrestre
voi dovete capire
che il vostro sistema
di tagliare la realtà
è vostro, della specie umana.
Funziona: però è un sistema,
come dire, costruito,
non è la realtà tutta.
Anche i poeti un pochino
tagliano la realtà in modo diverso;
i filosofi,
chi si occupa di religione, eccetera.
Però, questo tipo di persone
hanno la capacità di passare
da un registro all'altro.
Uno scienziato può vedere
tutti gli oggetti -
si occupa della questione degli atomi
che si muovono per il calore,
e distingue le cose
in atomi più fermi e atomi più mossi.
È un modo corretto di vedere la realtà:
però è capace di scendere
al registro della parola.
Il problema dei pazienti psichiatrici
è che loro non sono liberi
di scegliere il loro registro:
non riescono a comunicare
né con la parola,
né con questi livelli superiori.
Nella bizzarria del modo di ragionare,
c'è solo la confusione.
Non è un arricchimento,
non c'è un aumento di libertà
nell'avere un disturbo di questo tipo;
c'è una diminuzione della libertà.
Il paziente, in questa situazione,
se è angosciato è meglio,
perché vuol dire che c'è
una sua parte sana
che capisce che non è
una bella situazione.
Molti pazienti invece scherzano,
ridono, sono fatui:
è un segno negativo.
Come si comunica?
Si comunica col corpo.
Il paziente comunica con il corpo
perché non parla ma trema,
sbatte, si irrigidisce,
ha dei movimenti manierati.
Il nostro corpo comunica col suo corpo,
senza che noi ce ne rendiamo conto,
in una maniera un pochettino animale.
Io dico una cosa
che non deve offendere nessuno,
ma se due cani si incontrano per strada,
comunicano senza parlarsi.
Questa non è la comunicazione non verbale,
perché la comunicazione non verbale
è il mio gesticolare.
Questo è un tipo di comunicazione
più primitiva rispetto a quella
corticale, verbale, eccetera eccetera.
Un dato fondamentale
è che noi siamo degli animali,
cioè non esiste medicina,
psicologia, psichiatria -
nessuna scienza umana può evitare il fatto
che noi siamo degli animali,
quindi noi comunque possiamo comunicare
a dei livelli inferiori,
che però non sono consapevoli.
Il nostro corpo ci dà delle informazioni.
Per esempio, se io sono in una situazione
apparentemente tranquilla,
con un paziente apparentemente tranquillo,
ma - mi è successo, insomma, più volte -
e io comincio a provare dei brividi,
è il mio corpo che mi sta dicendo:
"Stai attento: c'è qualcosa
che non quadra".
Lo percepisco dal mio corpo,
prima di capirlo.
Noi, il corpo -
se sono con un depresso, sono stanco;
se ci sono dei pazienti che entrano,
e tu ti senti arrabbiato immediatamente,
sono i caratteriali.
Gli isterici, i maniacali?
Puoi sentire voglia di giocare,
con alcuni di questi.
Praticamente, il tuo corpo
ti fa la diagnosi: e la fa anche fine.
Per esempio, una diagnosi differenziale
tra pazienti di tipo
neurologico, psico-organico -
cioè fisici, con problemi fisici -
oppure psichiatrico,
è il fatto che tu senti, ma la senti -
noi sentiamo l'identità
come una specie di peso,
di sostanza che ha una massa.
E nel paziente neurologico,
in un demente, per esempio,
sentiamo che c'è un vuoto: non c'è.
Nel paziente con malattia fisica
c'è un po' di più.
Nel paziente psichiatrico è pesante,
perché il paziente,
per quanto sia psichiatrico,
pensa, ragiona, ha un sacco
di meccanismi mentali:
anche se non funzionano bene, ci sono.
Vi faccio un - mi ricordo una volta,
ma è successo diverse volte -
una persona viene ricoverata in reparto,
e io sento che questa persona
è completamente vuota: non esiste.
Io dico: ma dai, non è psichiatrica!
Chiamo il neurologo,
che l'ha vista in pronto soccorso
e le ha fatto un esame neurologico.
Ma il problema di questi casi è:
a questi pazienti, come fai a fare
un esame neurologico?
Infatti, il neurologo scrive:
"Per quanto possibile,
esame neurologico negativo".
Non ha la febbre, ma è vuoto.
Io insisto per telefono
con questa collega, dicendole:
guarda, fai una tac, una risonanza,
vedi te, fagli qualche cosa;
ma questo ha un problema fisico.
Lei mi dice: Ma Milone,
perché tu senti il vuoto io devo fare -
(Risate)
devo anche legarlo, poi devo sedarlo,
chiamare l'anestesista!
Perché adesso, se tu prendi una botta
contro la porta di casa,
vai in Pronto Soccorso
e ti fanno la TAC subito.
Con questi pazienti
non puoi seguire i protocolli,
perché c'è scritto:
"Se una persona arriva confusa,
fai l'esame neurologico;
e poi, a seconda di quello che trovi,
fai la TAC o la risonanza,
fai un sacco di altre cose".
Ma con queste persone
l'esame neurologico non funziona,
perché [non risponde alle istruzioni]:
stia fermo così, chiuda gli occhi.
Allora, vabbè, fa quello
che le ho detto io.
Questa collega poi mi fa una telefonata,
e dice: te lo veniamo a prendere
subito, ha una meningite -
mi sembra che fosse quella situazione.
E poi mi ha ringraziato.
Io mi sono stupito,
perché ho detto: ma guarda un po',
che io ho sentito un senso di vuoto
e corrispondeva.
Questa medicina, che sembra magia,
in realtà non è magia,
perché anche in una medicina
tecnologica e avanzata
servono queste cose,
specialmente nei pazienti
che non si fanno fare gli esami.
Perché uno dice: se uno sta male,
va in pronto soccorso,
gli faccio tutti gli esami
possibili del sangue, tutte le cose,
qualcosa salterà fuori.
Ma se lui non collabora,
non se la fa fare,
è importante che il medico
lavori in un certo modo.
Noi cerchiamo di contattare:
cosa facciamo noi?
Cerchiamo di contattare
la parte sana del paziente.
Gli psichiatri sono ottimisti. Sempre.
Ci sono quelli che dicono:
finché il paziente non parla,
non gli parlo neanche io.
Non ci possiamo capire.
Noi invece lavoriamo
come se ci fosse sempre
una parte sana che ci ascolta.
E a me è capitato più volte
che un paziente, quando è stato meglio,
e poi è stato dimesso, poi mi dicesse:
"Guardi, mi hanno portato in ospedale
ed ero convinto che mi avessero
portato lì per uccidermi.
Ho detto: mi stanno portando
nel posto dove mi ammazzano.
E arrivato lei, e ho detto:
questo dev'essere uno
di quelli che mi ammazzerà.
Poi lei ha cominciato,
tutti i giorni, a dirmi:
guardi che lei si chiama così e così,
che è in ospedale, questo ospedale,
che io mi chiamo così e così,
che lei è confuso,
le stiamo dando delle medicine,
in due, tre giorni, quattro giorni
dovrebbe migliorare.
Se non migliora, continuiamo:
abbia pazienza.
Io, a quel punto, ho cominciato a pensare:
ma vuoi vedere che non mi ammazzano subito
e che magari mi danno
qualche giorno di tempo?"
E a questa cosa lui ci si è agganciato,
e lo ha aiutato molto.
Chiudo dicendovi
che i ricoveri in psichiatria durano,
in genere, dai due ai sette giorni.
I pazienti - in genere,
perché la casistica è molto varia -
riprendono a parlare
dopo due o tre giorni.
La cosa incredibile,
la cosa molto positiva
è che il 90% dei pazienti
che si ricoverano per una psicosi acuta
migliorano tantissimo,
e migliorano molto più
che in altre specializzazioni mediche.
Come vedete, queste cose
non sono protocollabili:
non riguardano l'intelligenza,
riguardano altre cose.
Noi psichiatri abbiamo
questa caratteristica:
che non ci offendiamo
se ci dicono che siamo stupidi.
Noi ci offendiamo se ci dicono
che non siamo sensibili.
Però anche qui non è che dobbiamo gasarci:
perché secondo me, per esempio,
i commessi di un negozio di abbigliamento
sono molto più sensibili di noi,
quando vado [in un loro negozio] .
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)